[Music]
big storm coming
could be a twister
hey rick can you walk me through
something yeah what are you thinking
so you and morty knew you needed my help
but
you weren't sure i was good enough at
karate so you hired my grad students to
attack me
yep but it was an emergency rick
how long did that take it actually took
less training than you'd think
your students all shared a pretty keen
aptitude for martial arts
i don't know if that's by coincidence or
if there's some correlation with their
passion for african-american women's
studies
maya angelou did personify both
acquiescence and perseverance
that's exactly the kind of connection
i'd have loved to explore in my class
too bad i lost my job for putting my
students in the hospital
yeah yeah sorry about that
this seems like a good time for a drink
and a cold calculated speech with
sinister overtones
a speech about politics
about order brotherhood
power but speeches are for campaigning
now is the time for action
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new rick and morty
season 4 episode 3
video for the post credit scene and evil
morty i know a lot of big questions
about where he is what is he doing right
now when are we going to see him on the
show again
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the easter egg
videos we're doing a weekly merch
giveaway too all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
season 4 evil morty theory on the video
so careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
but in this post-credits scene at the
beginning they reference a storm coming
big storm coming and it's going to be a
twister
as in a big twist rick in the former
professor poopy butthole talk about the
logic behind the story of this week's
episode in the meta way while morty in
the background solves this rubik's cube
with a very distant very severe
evil morty-esque look on his face you
can see and hear this giant storm coming
in the distance and it gives the scene
a very ominous cast to it importance of
very bad things to come
the whole joke about the relationship
between maya angelou though and knowing
martial arts is because the students
were so interested in her that they
themselves tried to embody her ideas as
rick says
perseverance and acquiescence
acquiescence in the sense that they
would submit themselves to sitting in
his classroom all day to learn about her
in perseverance in that they had learned
to defend themselves and take action
when they felt threatened
then the joke with him directly
referencing the idea that he lost his
job because it's totally not okay to
fight with your students
so a lot of you in the last couple of
episodes have asked why haven't we seen
evil morty yet or any direct on-screen
references to him beyond the more subtle
ones when they start referencing the
events of season three and everything
that rick did
that led them to change their family
dynamic there was a clip with one of the
writers from episode 3
talking about being brand new to the
rick and morty writers room at the start
of this new 70 episode order and how
they had all this content that they had
to produce
in how the producers including dan and
justin gave them some basic guidelines
in terms of what kinds of references and
ideas for episodes they were supposed to
generate for this first block of
episodes
are there forbidden topics are there
hacky topics frequently pitched ideas
things to avoid
we were not encouraged to go back
and like find another mesex episode
because that's just
to to tunnel vision for finding a good
episode of the show
and probably because there's 70 episodes
left of the show it's like you don't
want to go
back to the well necessarily there is so
much more to find and more to create
that you know don't
narrow your view by thinking well what
do i have to go back and answer and
like there's time for all that stuff so
one of the examples that she gives is
that dan and justin the other producers
didn't want the writers going to look
for extra meeseeks episodes because they
didn't want them mining old bits over
and over again
there were 70 episodes that they had to
fill dan and justin aren't huge fans of
totally ripping themselves off
particularly this early in the run that
doesn't mean that they'll never bring
stuff back
and there were me seeks during the first
episode that's them being
cool with subtle references and jokes
about earlier bits that's why you saw a
very short but very big me seeks scene
you saw pickle rick you saw squanchy in
their visions
all bits from previous episodes in the
past but a lot of them were quick and
hard to spot if you weren't watching the
episode really carefully so they weren't
super on the nose about some of those
callbacks
and even with the meseeks one which was
a little more overt the producer
explained that the whole idea was the
meseek scene was meant to be a reference
how derivative and hacky morty's ideas
are
all versions of morty not just the main
version of morty during the episode but
also fascist morty where he keeps
repeating that he wants to go back to
old-fashioned
good old rick and morty adventures we're
going back to the way things used to be
so it was the writers making fun of the
morty character in a meta way making fun
of themselves and calling out a small
portion of the fandom that gets too
obsessed with their older bits
the difference with evil morty though is
that he's not a bit from an earlier
episode he's become one of the core
serialized elements of the show in
probably one of the biggest adversaries
that rick has been creating for himself
that's also been another recurring theme
in the last couple of episodes like
during episode 2 the mobster fly that he
threatens when he's looking for the
toilet bandit and he walks away without
killing them
and he tells rick that he's going to pay
for this but then rick basically doesn't
care he says it'll be worth it if i find
out who used my toilet
the creation of a whole other new plot
thread with a whole organization of
people that want rick's blood
and even though they haven't gone really
deep into serialized story elements in
the first three episodes
just remember what they said at the end
of episode one that ending scene where
they start yelling at each other about
the future of rick and morty
they said that season four is going to
be a mixture of serialized stories
one-offs like the heist episode and
episodes that were about nothing at all
the kind of joke which to me
feels more like a seinfeld reference
which famously marketed itself as a show
that was about
nothing just a bunch of people hanging
out and funny things happen to them
during the normal course of their day
in fact if you never saw it they
actually have a seinfeld deleted scene
from a previous episode
it didn't make it past animatic but it's
a genuine seinfeld scene
in a rick and morty episode hey morty
look it's seinfeld from a dimension
where he's completely unrelatable
oh turn it up rick what's the deal with
all these mexican bones under our house
why do we keep burying mexicans in the
basement i mean what's the deal
with these mexican bones they're so hard
to eat
hey boy you know rick i never found
seinfeld funny but this stuff really
gets me yeah you know morty
i think we finally found a seinfeld for
our generation okay cool okay change it
all right
ultra specific references like that feel
like they come from dan more than they
come from justin
but if you missed a lot of the coverage
of rick and morty season four during
comic-con this summer there was a clip
of them talking about a special moment
that would happen during a post-credit
scene in the first five episodes of
season four that would be a big teaser
for
things to come
i literally cannot stop thinking about
this tag we we
you guys don't know about it we have a
tag in season four
that's going to be some up in
season five now that's not them coming
right out and saying they're definitely
doing an evil morty post credit scene
reference
but they are pretty much saying that
outside of the normal funny stuff that
they do
in post credit scenes and call backs to
jokes within the particular episodes
they're implying it's supposed to tease
something really big is coming and mr
poopybutthole says a big storm is coming
rick says it will be a big twister as in
big twist
implying that they're going to be doing
something big with evil morty in the
second half of season four
for those of you asking when the second
block of episodes is going to air
based on adult swim's behavior in the
past until they say something official
early guesses that they'll come back at
the end of january right after the
christmas and new year's holidays
if you look back at the rick and morty
season 1 episode schedule they did
something very similar breaking that
season into two parts airing the first
half before christmas in the second half
after christmas but catching up with
evil morty the beginning of season four
the last we saw him he was beginning to
restructure the citadel of rick's
mortys in general were enjoying more
freedom more power he fired the teachers
that were giving them the old dogma
about how mortys were supposed to serve
their ricks
but beyond rebuilding the citadel itself
and creating his morty new world order
that was about it
tammy phoenix person the remnants of the
galactic government are still out there
somewhere
we know squanchy is out there somewhere
because there's a future timeline where
he winds up killing rick where he's all
squashed out
but i'm not expecting to see any of
those characters show up
really really soon mostly for the same
reason they're holding off on doing evil
morty citadel stuff
right away there's 70 more episodes so
they're just gonna ease into some of
that stuff
but post all your theories in the
comments do you think that they're
gearing up for a big evil morty citadel
return in the back half of season 4 next
year big storms coming
quick reminder that episode 4 is going
to be this weekend they were on break
this past weekend for thanksgiving i
will do no bonus video
soon so let me know what you want that
video to be about
congratulations alpha j 3.0 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big rick
and morty video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your details
everyone click here for the rick and
morty season 4 episode 4 trailer video
and click here for my new mandalorian
video about why the empire wants baby
yoda so bad
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you